Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is a caller
accurately identifying that right wingers are
better than left wingers at firing up their bases.
Speaker 5: Hello, David. Great show.
Listen all the time. Thank you, Brant. And
my question is, it seems like every
weekend the Republicans and the mega.
Radicals are holding a rally or pep rally
or an Deepak rally or turning point rally
into rally after rally after rally. However,
you don't see any of this on the left.
Is that a bigger problem? Or am I the only
one that thinks that the problem that.
The right has all these ridiculous
rallies and seems to rile up the base,
and the left has nothing to counter that.
Speaker 1: I have been saying this for
years. The pyrotechnics, the wrestling
style introductions, the explosive music,
everything. It's all pathetically cringe
worthy, and we all recognize it as such.
And also, it is more of the evidence. It's more
it's these are greater and greater examples
of how the right creates community and funds
this stuff to activate and engage and inspire
and fire people up in a way that the left
does not. Now, I'm not suggesting that
we try to fire people up in the exact
same way. I mean, a lot of this stuff,
it it appeals to the right more than it appeals to
the left. So I'm not saying we do the same thing,
but the left would greatly benefit from a decision
that we have to put more money into activating,
engaging and inspiring people. And if we don't,
we're we're going to lose the ground game,
and we continue to lose it in many ways. So, yeah,
the caller is 100% correct. On today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Pac-Man's a loser.
Speaker 1: I know Alex Jones hates the bonus,
so we are going to talk about Steve Bannon's
two guilty counts and his likely sentence.
We are going to talk about new sex education,
books rejected by a Florida school board.
And we will talk about support from two thirds of
Americans for term limits in the Supreme Court.
All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman icon.